the director of the World Health
Organization recently said something
very striking he declared the end of the
covid-19 pandemic is in sight how long
have we waited to hear that but with
hundreds still dying in the U.S every
day and thousands in the hospital what
exactly does that mean to address that
very question and questions about monkey
pox and flu season we're not we're
joined by someone at the table knows all
the answers to that Dr David agus good
morning is it too early to breathe a
collective sigh of relief because when I
heard it I I did finally what do you say
yeah you know two and a half years over
17 million people died of this pesky
virus so I do think we are at the end of
the pandemic but we're not over covet
19. so I do think covid-19 is going to
continue but it's not going to be a
pandemic that shuts things down we're
going to live with the virus people will
still get it we're not going to hide
from it people are still going to get it
on a regular case but we're going to get
those boosters it's not going to be
serious and if you have you know other
medical issues you'll get Pac slavid or
the antibodies we're going to live with
it and prevent hospitalizations it's a
lowest death rate on the globe since
March of 2020. and you say get the
booster the new booster that's coming
out I say yes definitely get that
booster several million people have
gotten it it's proven safe in those
people please get that booster broader
can you mix the boosters if you've been
a Pfizer girl or a modern or girl can
you can you mix them when you mix the
first time you mix you get a bump in
immunity so I got all Pfizer this time I
got moderna because I wanted that bump
with this new booster so yes you can mix
you look like a mixer yeah well I'm
going to mix yeah be a mixer and a same
day or meaning booster plus flu shot
yeah it's more side effects but
certainly the flu shot is important this
year was bad in Australia and for two
years you know 40 million people
normally get it a year they didn't so we
have less immunity to the flu so this
year especially get the booster kids
under nine who haven't had a flu shot
yet or only one in their lifetime
actually need to get to this year space
four weeks apart I don't understand your
thinking on getting them both at the
same time David because if you have a
reaction you're not going to know where
the reaction is coming from shouldn't
you know where the reaction action it's
coming from or does it not matter a lot
of people say listen convenience wise I
gotta work it's really hard for me to
get into anything and those people
should get it I think you should
separate if you can because there's
fewer side effects better you know
separate each one by a week which is
what I'm doing and my patients I'm
recommending but some people just
schedule wise can't do it and if you
can't medically it's okay for those that
are wondering are we on the other side
of the pandemic right now
yeah I think we are in this country I
mean we walk through the streets of New
York I saw one mask out of 100 people
and so I do think we're out of it at the
same time we're not over Cova 19 which
is really the message here we're going
to have to get used to it and we're
going to have to get used to testing
when we feel sick and staying home but
this is our regular Cadence I'm still
going to wear a mask on the plane I'm
flying to London I still I know they say
it's safe but it's still the flight
attendant doesn't wear it the pilot
doesn't wear it but I'm still going to
wear them you're going on vacation in
London yeah what's going on no I'll be
working what about monkey pox so monkey
pox significant declining cases but it's
still there it's still in this
population of individuals gay men
predominantly we need to get more
vaccines to them and if they do get it
we need to treat them because we have
treatments that work so monkey pox
unfortunately it's spread like wildfire
but now it's getting under control all
right Dr David Aegis thank you so much
we appreciate you we said he'd have all
the answers